>> Kimberly: AND
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE ALONG WITH
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
KENNEDY, AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
DO TO MEET BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AT THIS HOUR AND COULD VOTE AS
SOON AS THIS EVENING ON WHETHER
TO RELEASE THE SECRET MEMO THE
REPUBLICANS SAY SHOW
SURVEILLANCE ABUSES BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DOJ AND FBI.
KEEP IT ON FOX NEWS FOR THE
LATEST OF ELEMENTS.
IN OTHER NEWS, FRIDAY AFTER
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THAT HILLARY CLINTON HELPED
PROTECT A SENIOR ADVISOR TO HER
2008 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN WHO
WAS ACCUSED OF HARASSING A YOUNG
SUBORDINATE, SHE RESPONDED
TWEETING SHE WAS DISMAYED WHEN
>> HEY, EVERYONE.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THANKS.
THANKS FOR YOUR FEMINISM, YOUR
ACTION, AND ALL I CAN HOPE IS
YOU KEEP UP THE REALLY
IMPORTANT, GOOD WORK.
>> Kimberly: THEN THINGS TOOK
A MORE BIZARRE TURN.
>> LET ME SAY, THIS IS DIRECTED
TO THE ACTIVIST [BLEEP]
>> Kimberly: CLINTON
RESURFACED DURING LAST NIGHT'S
GRAMMYS WALKING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> HAD A LONG TIME FEAR OF
POISONED.
ONE REASON WHY HE LIKED TO EAT
AT McDONALD'S.
NOBODY KNEW HE WAS COMING.
>> THAT'S THE ONE.
>> Kimberly: KENNEDY, PLEASE
DECIPHER ALL OF THIS FOR US.
>> Kennedy: WHAT COMEDIC
GENIUS.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY DEMOCRAT
TRYING TO USE A POTTY MOUTH.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT YOUNG
VOTERS SINCE THEY ARE NOT
REACHING BACK TO EITHER PARTY.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED.
WHEN WE HEAR THESE STORIES ABOUT
HARASSING A YOUNG STAFFER,
HILLARY CLINTON, CHAMPION OF
OF THE WOMAN THAT SHE CALLED HER
LAST WEEK TO THREATEN HER WITH
PROTECTED TO MAKE SURE SHE
WOULDN'T COME FORWARD WITH MORE
STORIES.
WHAT IT SAYS TO ME AS YOU HAVE
FOUR PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAMPAIGN DEEPLY ENTRENCHED AND
SENIOR STAFFERS ON THE CAMPAIGN
WHO WANTED HIM OUT OF THERE AND
HE WASN'T FIRED.
SHOWS ME YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS DOING WHATEVER THEY
CAN TO BURY HER, TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM FOR A
DEMOCRATIC FIELD IN 2020 THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE HER NAME.
>> Kimberly: THEY DON'T WANT
TO LOSE AGAIN.
LOSING ISN'T FUN.
WINNING IS.
>> Greg: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
GRAMMYS.
SHORT FOR GRANDMOTHER.
LAST NIGHT'S RATINGS, THEY
DROPPED 10 MILLION HOUSEHOLDS.
THEY LOST 33% IN THE PRIME
DEMOGRAPHIC.
WHEREVER SHE GOES, SHE LOSES.
I'M WAITING FOR HER TO BLAME
THAT ON THE RUSSIANS COME THAT
THE RUSSIANS TINKERED WITH THE
RATINGS.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT THE
READING OF THE BOOK, THEY HAD
OTHER MUSICAL ARTISTS.
I THINK CHER DID IT.
THE EXCERPTS WERE ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP BEING BORED IN
MEETINGS AND WHAT HE EATS.
THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY.
A POP STAR WHO DEMANDS FIVE
BOTTLES OF CHAMPAGNE AND A
DONKEY.
THERE IS NO MORE PETULANT,
SELF-INVOLVED BEHAVIOR THAN A
POP STAR.
YOU KNOW THIS.
THEY WILL DEMAND THE COLOR OF
THE FURNITURE, THE TYPE OF
ROSES.
THEY ARE SPOILED ROTTEN.
RIDICULING DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE
HE GETS BORED IN THE MEETING,
THAT IS LIKE A CRAB CALLING ME
CRABBY.
THAT'S NOT'S.
THEY ARE HAVING A RELEVANT
DISCUSSION ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT.
THEY INCLUDE HILLARY, WHO IS
PROTECTED A SERIAL HARASSER
THIS IS PROBABLY WORSE, THE FACT
THAT THE CHARLIE HEBDO VICTIMS
HAD SPARKED THEIR OWN MURDERS BY
DRAWING MOHAMMED.
SHE IS ALWAYS BLAMING THE
VICTIM.
THE HYPOCRISY IS INSANE.
THERE'S A LOT MORE GOING ON
HERE.
THEY DEDICATED TIME TO CERTAIN
MUSICAL ARTISTS THAT PASSED AWAY
THAT HAD INTERESTING BACK
STORIES THAT WOULD NOT FIT INTO
THE "ME TOO" MOVEMENT.
>> Jesse: I HOPE GREG NEVER
GETS A HOLD OF MY WRITER.
>> Greg: AT THE GRAMMYS, THEY
ALSO READ FROM "SHATTERED" OR
"UNLIKABLE."
>> Jesse: I THINK HILLARY
CHEAPENS THE WHOLE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT.
SHE IS BEEN ACCUSED OF COVERING
UP SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND HER
HUSBAND'S WHITE HOUSE, HER OWN
STATE DEPARTMENT, AND NOW HER
OWN CAMPAIGN.
THE PEOPLE AND HER ORBIT, KEVIN
SPACEY, HARVEY WEINSTEIN, HUMA
ABEDIN'S HUSBAND.
LIKE YOU SAID, SHE'S BEEN
MARRIED TO A SERIAL HARASSER.
SHE'S BEEN A HYPOCRITE FOR SO
MANY YEARS.
SHE SAID DONALD TRUMP WAS
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS THEN
GOT CAUGHT PAYING A FOREIGN
AGENT TO COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
SHE SAID TRUMP WASN'T GOING TO
ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THE
LECTION, THEN SHE DIDN'T ACCEPT
THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
SHE HAD A TERRIBLE WEEKEND.
THE TWEET SHE SENT OUT WAS
RIDICULED BY THE RIGHT AND THE
LEFT, SO SHE WAS FORCED INTO
THIS WEIRD VIDEO AT DINNER AFTER
AND THEN SHE GETS A WHEELCHAIR
SHE SHOULD'VE READ      READ THG
SHE SHOULD'VE READ      READ TH,
WAS NOT WOLFF TO ACCUSE NIKKI
HALEY OF SLEEPING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO GET TO THE
TOP.
HILLARY DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
SHE FORGOT ABOUT THAT PASSAGE.
>> Kimberly: NIKKI HALEY WAS
NONE TOO PLEASED ABOUT THAT.
JUAN, YOU SEEM A LITTLE BIT
I WAS LOOKING FOR A SIGN.
>> Juan: SOMETIMES IT'S JUST
TOO MUCH.
LISTEN, APPARENTLY NOBODY HEARD
SHE LOST THE ELECTION.
>> Greg: TRUE, YOU ARE RIGHT,
INCLUDING HER.
>> Juan: AND APPARENTLY NOBODY
KNOWS ABOUT PEOPLE IN THE TRUMP
KINDS OF AWFUL STATEMENTS ABOUT
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Juan: NOW THEY ARE CHIRPING
BECAUSE THEY REALIZE THEY HAVE
BEEN STUMPED.
>> Greg: YOU ARE NOT
LISTENING.
READING SOMETHING COMEDIC FROM
HOW DO YOU GET THAT THAT IS
SOMEHOW HILLARY CLINTON IN
EVIDENCE OF HER HYPOCRISY.
MY GOSH, IT'S NOT WRITTEN BY A
LIBERAL.
IT'S WRITTEN BY A CONSERVATIVE
AND IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE, GUESS
WHAT, THEY HAVE WON GRAMMYS FOR
BOOK READING.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE READING FROM THE
TRUMP BOOK.
I THINK IT WAS FUNNY.
SHE DID LOSE.
GIVEN THE CHOICE, WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU RATHER BE THE LOSER ON
AN AWARDS SHOW THAT'S LOSING
VIEWERS.
YOU WOULD CHOOSE TO BE PRESIDENT
AND NOT HER.
IT'S A PATHETIC, SOLO
PERFORMANCE.
I AM AGREEING WITH YOU.
IT >> Juan: THAT IS MY POINT.
UP BOND BECAUSE YOU CAN'T DEFEND
TRUMP.
YOU HAVEN'T MENTIONED TRUMP AND
THE PORN STAR.
WHY DON'T WE TALK ABOUT THAT?
>> Jesse: IT IS HYPOCRITICAL
THAT SHE COVERED UP SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
>> Juan: THINK OF THE FACTS.
>> Kimberly: THOSE ARE THE
FACTS.
>> Juan: YOU CAN MAKE A RIGHT
WING CASE WITHOUT LYING.
>> Jesse: I AM NOT LYING.
WHAT DID SHE DO WITH THE WOMAN
>> Kimberly: HANG ON.
LET ME GET KENNEDY IN HERE.
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH.
>> Kimberly: JUAN, YOU ARE
FILIBUSTERING.
>> Juan: SHE SAID LET'S GET
THIS GUY INTO TREATMENT AND GOOD
THING THE YOUNG WOMAN CAME
FORWARD.
IT ALLOWED HER TO HAVE A CHOICE.
>> Kennedy: CORRECT THE
RECORD.
HE ONLY LASTED A FEW MONTHS
BECAUSE HE DID THE EXACT SAME
THING.
THE TREATMENT DIDN'T EXACTLY
WORK.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK HE
WENT.
ON THE BACK FOR LISTENING TO
WOMEN AND SAYING WE ALL DESERVE
TO BE HEARD.
YES, UNLESS THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACCUSING THEIR HUSBAND OR
PEOPLE AROUND HER OF
SEXUAL IMPROPRIETY.
>> Juan: IN THIS CASE, I THINK
YOU SHOULD NOT GO FULL BORE.
LET'S HAVE FAIR PROCESS.
EVEN IN BIG COMPANIES, PEOPLE
ARE ALLOWED TO SPEAK.
>> Kimberly: LOOK AT WHAT SHE
DID TO THE WOMEN.
>> Juan: I THINK
HILLARY CLINTON TOOK THE
APPROPRIATE AND LEGAL STEPS.
IF YOU ARE ASKING ME, SHOULD
SHE --
>> Jesse: AGAINST THE ADVICE
OF HER CAMPING CHARWOMAN WHO
SAID THEY WOULD       SHOULD BEF
SAID THEY WOULD       SHOULD BER
SAID THEY WOULD       SHOULD BED
SAID THEY WOULD       SHOULD BE.
>> Jesse: YOU SCORED ON
YOURSELF.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT THIS HAD
TAKEN PLACE IN THE 2016
CAMPAIGN.
IT WENT BACK TO 2008.
>> Kimberly: DOESN'T MAKE IT
OKAY.
WHETHER IT HAPPENED IN 2008 OR
LAST WEEK.
>> Kennedy: IN LIGHT OF HER
HUSBAND.
I THINK WE KNOW ENOUGH IN 2008
TO SHIELD PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
THIS    THIS IS AN #MeTooMovemet
THIS    THIS IS AN #MeTooMoveme.
>> Kimberly: HER RECORD IS
NOT STELLAR.
HILLARY HYPOCRISY AS IT RELATES
TO THE PRODUCTION OF WOMEN AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, ALL OF THOSE
SCATTERED TEACHABLE MOMENTS HER
HUSBAND TOSSED OUT IN FRONT OF
HER PEERS >> Juan: SO YOU ARE
AFTER THE HUSBAND.
>> Kimberly: I AM TALKING
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Greg: ONE LAST POINT.
TALKING ABOUT IT AND SEEN THESE
ARENAS EXPRESSING GENDER
EQUALITY.
IT'S TOUCHING TO SEE, BUT WHO
EXPRESSES GENDER EQUALITY MORE?
FOX NEWS OR THE MUSIC INDUSTRY
OR THE GRAMMYS?
THE GRAMMYS AWARDED, 70% OF
THEIR AWARD WINNERS WERE WOMEN.
MOST WEREN'T ALLOWED SOLO
PERFORMANCES.
>> Kennedy: ONLY PERSON
NOMINATED FOR ALBUM OF THE YEAR,
ONLY PERSON NOT INVITED.
NOT TO SING A SOLO PERFORMANCE.
>> Greg: MY POINT IS THERE
WERE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
THERE.
MY POINT IS 70% OF THE AWARDS
WON BY WOMEN AND THEY CAN'T
LECTURE US ANYMORE.
I'M SORRY.
I THINK THESE AWARDS SHOWS HAVE
THEY ARE TRAPPED IN THEIR OWN
MYOPIC EMOTIONAL WORLD AND THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT AMERICA IS
"SHUT UP."